there's something quite primal about
being in a tree something that just
feels really safe
it's just great
go climb a tree
an arborist
is somebody who takes care of the trees
we
prune maintain remove if dangerous
really the whole healthcare of a tree
in melbourne we're quite lucky in in the
ranges there's trees up there that are
85 90 meters really really big trees
at the moment i'm
about 24
22 24 meters up a tree
in a beautiful old red gun this old tree
we're in today is maybe 250 years old
and
it would be such a shame for the
landscape to lose something like this
is it dangerous it probably yeah it must
be really dangerous it means one of the
most dangerous jobs in the world
apparently
every single tree has something
different that you have to put into it
that hole is just big enough to take one
of the syringes and hopefully prevent
all these leak miners from attacking
those leaves working with trees and
understanding trees and having a respect
for trees is the only way i think you
can really then cut the trees
the thing is
sometimes the tree needs to come down if
there's an obvious failure or disease or
something then we're the best ones to
come out
remove it safely and advise about how we
can replant
we're here actually trying to preserve
and look after the trees because we
very much have an affection for them